hello everyone and welcome to another
impressive game uh from pool a of the uh
feed a grand prix 2022 currently being
played in berlin uh it's hikaru nakamura
versus andreas sipenko and as you know
hikaru uh pretty much uh stopped playing
classical chess he's now uh
more into streaming more into growing
his brand uh and uh from time to time he
plays a blitz or a rapid tournament but
classical i think the last time he
played was in 2020 uh he played in the
us us championship uh so fida decided as
he has a lot of followers we are going
to invite him that will be good for the
promotion of chess so it's uh very
interesting to see how he will do uh in
classical against all of these very
strong classical players so this is um
the game is very interesting
uh let's check it out and see what
happens so hikaru with the white pieces
opens with c4 he goes for the english uh
sorry about that
uh espenko goes e5 uh we have knight to
c3 knight to f6 and of course we have
the four knights of the english knight
of three knights to c6 and now g3
preparing to fianca to the light square
bishop uh we have d5 yes penguin strikes
in the center we have captures captures
in the now bishop to g2 we have bishop
to c5
nicely developing pieces and both
players castle so hikaru castles his
bingo castles and queen to c2 now just
developing the queen knight back to f6
and now there is a game where d3 was
played but here is panko plays a6 and it
is now uh as of uh sorry uh a
a3 and it is now as of move nine that we
have a completely new game uh so here
knights to d4 attacking the queen and
the knight so basically forcing the
trade on d4 we have knight captures e
captures but now hikaru doesn't react to
this he doesn't move the knight uh of
course pawn to b4 he says you're gonna
uh will if you capture my knight i'm
gonna win the bishop so here bishop back
to b6 but when you have the option of
retreating to b6 or e7 e7 is usually the
safer square but here is pinko decides
to go for b6 and now hikaru says all
right i will i will have the bishop pair
so here rook to e8 putting pressure on
the e2 pawn at first we eliminate the
bishop a captures in the now e3
so uh what can what can spankle do here
of course he's going to play d3 and
challenge white's queen so he carl plays
queen the c3 and now knight the e4 with
an attack on the queen and here uh you
might think okay let's capture the
knight but then you've given up your
light square bishop and this is a very
strong defender your opponent still has
a light core bishop so you could have
some problem defending the light squares
however here it kind of could work for
example captures captures in bishop b2
we're threatening checkmate now black
has to react to this f6 will have to be
played at some point because this is
just too strong of a battery
and now f3 we kick away the rook and
after the rook moves for example queen
c4 let's say king chair rook if the c1
and the white will have excellent
pressure here uh for the uh for the
entire game so it is possible hikaru
decides to for the moment keep the
bishops queen to c4 first uh we have
bishop to f5 and now bishop to b2 uh we
have queen to d7 now connecting the
rooks developing the queen also we might
have some bishop to h3 ideas in the
future not for the moment as the knight
would be hanging so here
uh hikaru just gives up the the light
square bishop it's uh it's the correct
thing to do captures captures and now f3
and now while you could go back for
example to g6 uh here he goes bishop to
c6 uh you will uh for the moment you're
defending the c7 pawn because you know
that white will be doubling or tripling
up on the c file so rook ate the c1 and
now rook to e7 ready to defend if b5 is
ever played okay for the moment it's not
possible but
maybe in the future so queen to f4 uh
and now uh we have f6 uh this is uh this
has to be played at some point because
it's simply too strong
we have rooked to c4 a nice rook lift
preparing to double up here with rook f
the c1 and rook to d8 now uh we have
rook f to c1 even though rook to d4 is
uh also playable rook after c1 uh we
have queen to e6 that's not a queen
queen to e6 as of course rook to d4 will
be an idea always uh and now hikaru
plays a pawn to b5 and of course we want
to give up that pawn uh for the c7 pawn
as you see you can see everything is
attacking the c7 pawn
but not quite like that you know uh you
want to capture on c7 but not
immediately because after bishop
captures on b5 hikaru doesn't capture on
c7 even though that's what you guys uh
want to do he plays rook the e4 and this
is not much better we're first going to
trade rooks and then we're going to play
rook captures in c7 and then our rook
remains on the c7 square so queen f7
rook captures on e7 queen captures and
now rook captures in c7 attacking the
queen
rook to d7 blocking and now rook the c8
check we have rook to d8 and now
now comes a very very interesting
variation that
i could ask you to pause the video now
but i'm going to ask you to do it on the
on the next move so here hikaru played
bishop captures on f6 and the move is
great because of one particular move uh
g captures on f6 and now what do you
play okay uh queen captures on f6 is
also possible but then we just trade
queens and we pick up the rook and the
end game is winning for white so instead
g captures on f6 was played but now
comes a move that you had to see in
order to play all of this uh to win the
game with white so feel free to pause
the video and try to try to find this
movie cover played while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredibly tricky idea and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is queen to g4 with check uh so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are an excellent uh spotter of
uh incredibly tricky lines uh uh but
yeah for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show that's the that's the
move and the problem is it doesn't
matter what uh black does uh and uh king
to f8 is what was played in the game but
just to show you if king to f7 we can
just pick up the rook and after the rook
is captured queen h5 check will pick up
the bishop and after the king moves uh
then the the the queen and pawn in the
game will be winning for us because
black's pawn structure is just
completely messed up and you're gonna
win this very easily another thing if
king the h8 this is also very easily
winning because of queen to b4 another a
very cool move you have to spot because
now if you trade queens first we pick up
the rook with check and only after the
king moves we pick up the queen and
again this end game will be winning for
us and the other thing is well you can
play queen d7 but now it's just captures
captures and we pick up the bishop again
the queen and pawn end game is winning
for us so yes pinko tried king to f8
it's not much better but
there's really not all that much he can
do here uh we have captures captures and
now queen to be for check we win the
bishop this way so queen e7 queen
captures on b5 and now queen captures an
a3 is panko grabs the pawn and now the
material is equal
but uh hikaru has one pawn island and
it's a one very long impressive pawn
island whereas black has four islands uh
four pawn islands and not only that a
doubled b pawn so king f2 and now uh
what can you play here with black
everything is attacked here and nothing
is uh well going well for black there's
no way to move the queen or pick up the
d2 pawn somehow because if you stop
defending d3 then queen captures on d3
and then black has no more counter play
whatsoever so here queen c5 yes panko
offers a queen trade but now queen
captures on d3 he starts pushing his
pass b pawn because that's the only
thing he has now
and the queen to c3 uh offering a queen
trade and stopping the push for the
moment queen to e7 and now king to e2 we
have king to g7 queen to d4 and now
queen to f7 yeah it's very hard to
start pushing those pawns but you don't
really have a move here so queen g4
checking the h8 now queen b4 and the
queen to e8 we have queen to d6 and just
uh winning more squares it's um
uh
pretty much uh
game over for black uh there's really no
move you can make queen to f7 was played
now comes queen to c5 queen to e8 and
now g4 just grabbing more more space
here king g7 with h4 queen to d7 and now
h5 we have king to g8 h6 and he was in
this position on move 46 that uh andreas
pinko resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so you
can't push any of the pawns the queen
controls pretty well just uh every
square on the board uh and other than
that you can't really do anything you
give give white one move for example
queen here and you are getting destroyed
so there's no move that black can play
here so very very uh interesting game he
car wins with the white pieces he takes
the lead in his pool a or or the a group
or what's it called uh so he's doing
very well so far we'll see if all this
uh taking break from classical chess
will do actually wonders for his
classical chess maybe uh maybe we get
hikaru in the candidates tournament
we'll see how it goes uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys uh enjoyed it i
would like to uh wish a very happy
birthday to rohan chaudhary and i would
like to thank thank uh it have a small
pp david kimura fred ackerman and triple
triangle for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
grand prix as it's very very important
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent
rest of your weekend